global warming would be a whole lot
worse if it wasn't for the world's
plants sucking up carbon dioxide
since 1960 they've absorbed around a
quarter of all
fossil fuel emissions and the amazon has
been a big part of that
it contains an estimated billion
tons of carbon but new research shows
the amazon basin
is in trouble in the west it is
absorbing slightly more carbon than is
being released from dead rotting trees
and human impact but in the south and
the east
which accounts for more than a quarter
of the amazon area has become a net
source of carbon and scientists fear
it's at a tipping point where great
swathes
could be lost in a self-perpetuating
cycle of decline
longer talking about some dystopian
future this is stuff we can see on the
ground these changes are happening here
and now
and these are in a sense the beginning
it's a warning of what is still to come
because we know we are moving towards
that inexorable
situation whereby the forest will slowly
transform into a more grassland savannah
type type ecosystem
and as a result we will start pushing
more and more carbon into the atmosphere
so what's the cause well the amazon gets
more than two
meters of rain a year on average between
a quarter and a third of that results
from moisture that's released by trees
but the amazon's climate is changing
particularly in the east
now over the last 40 years rainfall at
times of the year has decreased
by up to a third and temperatures have
increased
by up to two and a half degrees the
scientists say there is a clear link
with deforestation
in the east around a quarter of the
amazon has been cleared
mostly for agriculture more than twice
as much
as the west the fires used to clear the
forest release huge amounts of carbon
but the absence of trees also dries out
the surrounding forest
raising the risk of more fires as well
as stunting its growth
and reducing carbon uptake the
conservation charity wwf says
it's bleak but not too late to stop a
runaway decline
if brazil stops further deforestation
and switches
to more sustainable use of agricultural
land